hello and welcome to safety Ridge on
Sunday well last year 45 000 people
crossed the channel on small boats are
desperate and dangerous journey and
those are only the ones that we know
about well politicians have promised and
failed to tackle the issue before so
it's fair to say there was some
skepticism that Rishi C9 could be any
different when he made small boats one
of his five key priorities for 2023 well
today we hear the plan anyone who comes
to the UK illegally will be banned from
claiming Asylum will it work and is it
fair we'll try and find out on the show
today oh and we're also now on day five
of those Matt Hancock WhatsApp messages
which are everything from embarrassing
to excruciating I do wonder if I guess
I've had a little check this morning to
see if they've got any incriminating
messages with the former Health
secretary that might be waking their way
to the front page of a newspaper
well on the program today we are going
to be talking to the Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris for the
government for labor will speak to the
party Shadow work and pension secretary
Jonathan Ashworth
and as the PM and other parties in
Northern Ireland wait for the verdict of
the unionist dup on that deal with the
EU we'll teach the we'll speak to the
woman who would have been first Minister
Michelle O'Neill of champagne
also this morning the strategically
important Eastern Ukrainian town of
bakmut is threatened by Russian forces
we'll be talking to the former Chief of
the defense staff here Lord Dallas
and we'll also be going live to Kiev to
speak to the Ukrainian MP obana Klim
pushed Cincinnati
[Music]
[Applause]
hello happy Sunday let's start this
morning shall we hearing from the
government a few moments ago I spoke to
the Northern Ireland secretary Chris
Heaton Harris
what is the plan on tackling small boats
well I mean there's a whole host of
actions that we are taking and need to
take and what the Prime Minister said
it's one of his key priorities is to
stop the small boats what the premise is
saying is that we also need some
legislation on top of what we are doing
um so we can make sure that people who
come to this country illegally are
returned very quickly and I that's I
what I expect to see in the legislation
so just on the legislation is it right
the reports this morning that if you
come to the UK illegally then you're
going to be banned from claiming Asylum
I believe so yes so those can be it's
black and white legislation is very
black and white and how are you going to
change the law
um I don't know oh it's not my portfolio
but um we get a cabinet briefing
pre-announcement and we've been talking
about this for quite some time
um so I don't know the actual words of
the legislation but I'm very uh I know
it has to be extremely clear because
um like in my own portfolio of Northern
Ireland I know if you're not clear
um people are picking it and we're
expecting it Tuesday is that right I've
got no idea okay
um so what will happen to these people
then if you you know arrive on a small
boat you're banned from claiming Asylum
what will happen to them we're going to
go back to their own country they're
going to be taken to Rwanda yeah well
quite possibly all of those things or
any of those things but also there is um
part of this is actually making sure
that we have a very strong good
relationship with France which the Prime
Minister has been building because there
are you know we need France also to help
us in this situation part of it's also
other European countries through which
these people travel they're trafficked
um before they before they come here so
um we part of this is also you could say
in our International Aid budget uh where
we are trying to make sure people uh
economies are built uh properly so
people don't feel the need to travel
from the original country so it's a
whole batch of different things but
should people come to this country
illegally
um then um yeah they will be returned or
sent to somewhere like Randa which is a
legal scheme proven to be so in the high
court as we move forward
um so obviously to stay in this country
and to claim asylum in the future you're
going to need to do so through a legal
route now there are clear legal routes
to claim Asylum if you're from Ukraine
Afghanistan or Hong Kong if you're not
for one of those countries what is the
legal route yeah well there'll be I mean
I'm quite sure there'll be more safe and
legal routes and that's why
um you know and that's why we have them
and you're quite right they've been
proven to work
um and actually the level of illegal uh
Asylum illegal migrants coming to this
country the way that a number that come
in of course all sorts of ripples even
in my own constituency where we have a a
couple of the hotels that uh house
um uh the the people who come across in
small boats have caused quite some
ripples in local communities that have
been very comfortable with the level of
migration that we've had up until this
point and so reports in the community
we've also seen some quite aggressive
processes
and yeah people get there are lots of
people who are triggered in all sorts of
ways um by this level of illegal
immigration into our country so we do
need to deal with this I uh you
mentioned there that there should be
more more legal routes into the UK which
feels crucial to me because the point I
was trying to get at is that for many
people if you're from I don't know Syria
or another war-torn country there may
not be a legal route to get to the UK
other than the small boats so is that
something you're going to try and change
well I mean that that is obviously for
the premise and the Home Secretary but
um they're also all the different
skilled routes that for skilled by uh
migrants coming to the country as well
yeah because we're talking about Asylum
Seekers yeah we're talking people who
may not be able to you know come through
the normal economic and skilled routes
people who work fleeing and it's not it
really isn't for me as Northern
secretary to say what what they should
be that's you know for the policy makers
in the home office and for the Prime
Minister
um but the safe and legal Roots way has
been proven to work as you say in a
whole host of occasions over a hundred
thousand Hong Kong Chinese
um uh everybody knows um ukrainians in
their community that have come here and
been truly welcomed I have a I still
have a hotel um full of people from
Afghanistan who who fled right at the
last minute from
um Kabul
um you know just about 18 months ago
um who have been truly welcomed into the
those local communities and so it's
really important that we need to get
this right and you think that it should
be expanded so that other people who are
not from the countries that are
mentioned
um should be having I think this that
safe and legal Roots is is absolutely
the way forward and we should welcome
people who come through those routes
okay and I want to talk brexit but
before we do Ukrainian forces are under
real pressure right now in back moots uh
reports on the Sunday Times that Rishi
senac is set to announce billions of
pounds more funding for the defense
budget um next weekend when you visit
the US is that right
um again that speculation that's a
pre-budget and you you know about an
idea that you'll have loads of
politicians sat here just before a
budget from the government who can't say
a word about the forthcoming budget but
what I do know is that uh in Northern
Ireland there's a fantastic company to
us who are making the entires that have
been doing such a good job for Ukrainian
forces
um uh on the battlefield in in Ukraine
and I know that we as a country and the
Prime Minister has completely
make behind making sure that we continue
our support
um thank you very much well we'll we'll
have more but on Ukraine in the program
as well over some interviews from Keith
coming up too now I want to talk brexit
with your Northern Ireland uh hat on um
unionists of course are very unhappy
about any idea that Northern Ireland
could be treated differently from the
rest of the United Kingdom now you must
be having conversations with a dep all
of the time are they going to back the
deal
um well that's really up to them I mean
we're currently are we
I I understand as a as a Euro skeptic um
you know that actually uh eurosceptics
and units have been let down a couple of
times before
um by the protocol and within Theresa
May's deal uh as well and so
um in in getting to the place that we've
got to you know we're very keen to make
sure that people can read all the texts
and you know if we publish it early no
one's being bounced into everything
everybody's got the time and space so
some people thought that they were being
bounced into it right we had on the show
last Sunday we had members of the
eurosceptic group uh saying that they
were being bounced into they haven't
been seen the legal tax yeah but um now
they have and now they've had a nearly a
week to digest it and you know there's
still some more time before we get
anywhere near having a vote in the
Commons and I know the ERG style chamber
is I'm former chair of the ERG I I I
welcome its work in this area because um
I want them to be convinced as I am that
this is a really good deal for the
people of Northern Ireland
um and to understand all the
implications of it and so they will be
about them when when's that going to be
um well there'll be a vote at some point
when when people have had the proper
time to digest what's in the text you
know we're giving it lots of time and
space to people so the um original
question the dep
um obviously is up to them what they do
but you must have a sense of it you're
having conversations with them right
yeah but this is a I actually think
there are a range oh I know there are a
range of views within the dup themselves
and so
um it's not for me to manage another
party I was
of course Johnson's Chief whip it was
very difficult just to manage my own so
I'm not going to second guess what a a
another political party will do but
they've asked for clarifications in in a
number of areas and we are going to give
them that clarification there's
technical talks that are ongoing with
all the political parties in Northern
Ireland this coming week about how the
storm won't break will work because
that's a new uh Innovative way of making
sure that you know people do have a
democratic say over some of the rules
that affect them so let's talk about
that shall we because that was one of
the clarifications as you said that some
people are looking for
um it would effectively allow
politicians in Northern Ireland to have
say over new legislation passed in
Brussels is it an actual veto or is it
just a delaying mechanism that's a veto
so if um storm one and the UK raised
concern the legislation is suspended for
four weeks
yeah but there's so there is a yeah when
the concern is raised that is when the
delay kicks in and when it goes through
the complete process the UK government
can veto How likely do you think it is
that the UK government will be willing
to veto EU law I think if it was going
to affect Northern Ireland in a
significant way we would veto EU law
because the EU have said the measure can
only be used in the most exceptional
circumstances and as a matter of Last
Resort yeah and we've said that it's got
to have significant you know we've used
the significant um uh the word
significant because it has to have you
can't be using a veto trivially but I
don't think actually the Northern
Ireland assembly would be using that uh
that uh trivially and I think this is
actually quite a it's a new thing it's a
treaty change it's being written into
Article 13 3A for those that are really
interested of the protocol
um and and that's it's a proper break a
proper veto
um but I I like to think and I having
got to know many of the mlas members of
the legislative assembly in Northern
Ireland that they would only use it
sensibly at unionists are also worried
about the extent to which EU law will
still apply in Northern Ireland which of
course matters as the UK diverges from
the EU in the future so you know if
there are future trade deals with our
countries and can you guarantee that
people and businesses in Northern
Ireland will be able to participate that
in those in exactly the same way as the
rest of the UK yeah I think we can and
and also I mean there is so there is
about we're now left with about three
percent of what was existing uh uh EU
law is going to be in place after this
gets adopted and that's the bare minimum
required to allow northernlining
businesses the access they have to the
European single Market which is really a
guarantee
um that Northern Ireland will be able to
participate in trade trade deals in the
future if you diverge from EU law and
single Market rules at Northern Ireland
you know yeah
that's one of the a very big differences
between this deal and the any previous
protocol or uh you know various articles
that people thought did the job
um we're also going to um and you're not
worried that this that quote's not going
to be played back to you in like six
months time when the EU says actually no
that's not a Northern Ireland can't
apply for these rules and the trade deal
that you've signed with you know the
states or whatever it is I'm generally
not worried about that okay okay
confident yeah and at the heart of this
of course is the fact that Northern
London is still in paralysis you know
someone is still not sitting there's no
government there
if a deep you don't back the deal if
they still continue to refuse to
participate in the Northern Ireland
assembly what are you going to do yeah
well I mean it's first that's a
theoretical question I mean I want to
get over the next couple of weeks and
hopefully be able to clarify all the
questions that the dep and actually
others in the unionist community have
and indeed others in the northern
political parties have
um I'd like to think that at that point
we will be able to get the executive up
and running
um but I've already already in fact last
week we were passing legislation through
Parliament uh called the executive
formation act
which allows me to have the opportunity
to call elections at any point during
the next year should that be required
there are other and there are there are
other routes for them we need to do
things on governance if that is the case
however
I'm a glass awful man I believe we can
get this right I think um The Windsor
framework is an Amazing Leap Forward
um I I do think it actually delivers on
all the questions that have been asked
we need to clarify some of those for for
some of the unions Community I'm
absolutely up for doing that is there a
time frame by which if someone isn't up
and running you're going to say right
that's it I need to push the button on
an election no I've learned I've learned
from previous lessons in Northern
Ireland that you don't set time frames
and even if you have one in your mind
you would never give it publicly okay
and now you clearly think this is a good
deal for Northern Ireland and the rest
of the UK I just want to play you what
the Prime Minister said when he
announced the details of the deal let's
have a listen
Northern Ireland is in the unbelievably
special position unique position in the
entire world European continent in
having privileged access not just to the
UK Home Market but also the European
Union single Market nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize
can you think of any other countries
that used to have you know the benefit
to that prize as well access to the UK
market and the single one yeah I hear
your question and actually it was
interesting I was interested in in the
in the statement that um when the Prime
Minister made a statement on Monday
evening that um apply cumbrian and and
Scottish nationalists were saying oh we
quite like yeah it sounds like a good
idea like that deal
um but we have the benefits of leaving
the European Union and we've got a uh
the uh cooperation agreement trading
cooperation agreement with the European
Union
um and now having sorted the protocol
out I believe that Northern Ireland is
in the position that the Prime Minister
uh said it uh said it's interesting you
mentioned there
um people in Scotland and Wales saying
we quite like the deal that Northern
Ireland has I mean particularly in
Scotland where people voted to remain
can you see that there may be an
argument that actually they should be
able to have the kind of yeah so they
they are gonna we are going to benefit
from as a whole country now from from
leaving the European Union and not
having not having laws imposed honest
that we have no control over Scotland as
well Northern Ireland was not in that
place because there's always been some
sort of agreement or protocol that has
not allowed Northern Ireland
um to leave the European union now
that's what we are we are completing
that job and Northern Ireland by
accepting that there's going to be this
three percent of EU laws the bare
minimum will also maintain its um
position the Prime Minister was
outlining you're you're a skeptic
obviously expects that made us poor one
uh no what the OBS that predicts both
exports and imports will be 50 lower in
the long run than if the UK had remained
in the EU the bank of England predicts
the UK suffering loss of business
investment worth 29 billion I understand
the arguments about autonomy about
democracy on has it made us poorer you
say no I say no what's your evidence for
that um my evidence is that we're we are
still a growing economy we're doing
really well we've had we're the only
Parts in the country in the G7 to have a
smaller economy than pre-funded yeah but
it depends on which year you're managed
measuring and and where actually I think
people
it doesn't depend it doesn't depend on
what year you're measuring if you look
at our pre-pandemic economy size we're
the only country that G7 to have a
smaller one so but people I'm a great
believer that this country has got a
much better future that will grow
quicker or having left the European
Union I believe actually we're just
about to prove that and in Northern
Ireland we're going to prove it even
more because of the deal that we've just
struck on under and under the Windsor
framework now
um I think it's very difficult to
measure like with like because of a
whole host of things that have happened
since brexit there was absolutely a
stutter after brexit
um economically but it's very difficult
to measure that because covert then came
very quickly uh the war in Ukraine came
very quickly yeah every country hasn't
it not just ours yeah but in very
different ways in many different ways
okay now
divorce Johnson
he has said that the new deal is not
about the UK taking back control it will
act as a drag anchor or Divergence from
the EU and as a result he'll find it
difficult to vote for it have you spoken
to the former prime minister of aladil
yeah I've read a couple of conversations
with him and um you know I was his chief
whip so I'd like to think by the time we
get to a vote out of cunningly persuaded
him that he actually needs to vote for
the deal are you optimistic that you're
going to be out succeed in persuading
him um well Boris is a is a law into
himself in many ways but he's a he's a
great man A wise man an honest man and I
believe he'll
come to see that it's a good idea you
say he's an honest man
uh the privilege committee is
investigating whether he misled
parliaments over partygate is he a man
of integrity yes 100
um because of course if he's found to
you have misled Parliament
do you think that is going to impact his
career do you think it'll happen I don't
think he'll be found to have Mr
Parliament I didn't when I became his
chief whip it was we're just uh all this
all this past gate stuff had started
um I saw him behind the scenes I know
exactly what he's like
um I do not believe for one second Boris
knowingly Miss Ned Parliament you don't
believe it but that's a different
question to whether he is found of
misled Parliament by the Privileges
committee and I have to say the evidence
that they've really so far suggests it's
trending in One Direction I I think he
you in this country you're innocent
until you're proven guilty and I think
that um I I'm absolutely convinced
um Boris did not know me Miss Lee
Parliament
um allies of Boris Johnson have uh
thrown a bit of mud should we say in the
direction of Sue gray who of course was
leading the inquiry into pilot
Parliament from the Civil Service she's
now going to go and become kirstan as
chief of staff is that problem
no I don't I so I think it's actually
this is where care can help out his his
new chief chief of staff by just
publishing all the messages and things
he might have had with her at that point
in time I've dealt with Sue gray as a in
the Northern Ireland office as a civil
servant um I see her as a woman of
Integrity as well so I I have no issue
with that and I think could clear clear
this up in seconds by saying no there's
no this is this is what we talked about
at that time there was nothing there's
nothing to see here she'll know a lot of
secrets about your party though won't
you I'm sure she was the head of
proprietary and ethics
um so uh she will know quite a lot about
individuals but
I'm
she is I truly believe she is a lady of
Integrity so I'm not worried by that
okay
okay before we uh and delete WhatsApp
messages in the Daily Telegraph show he
wanted to use a new covered variant to
frighten the pants off everyone and make
sure they complied with the rules
um can you understand why that might be
quite tough reading for people who found
lockdown very difficult yeah I mean I
read I've read the the piece myself and
it did actually mention
um that the New Kent variant had already
you know there was a thousand cases
um but
the problem with uh this particular
story is that we're just seeing a
partial account all the time now there
is a independent inquiry that's been set
up that has got access and will have
access to all the evidence that's
available so I actually think we should
probably wait and see what that inquiry
defines is it appropriate to conduct so
much government business on WhatsApp
um well so again we're in lockdowns and
how do you communicate with people email
um official channels so every decision
would have been recorded officially so
but I mean what you're seeing in in
these messages are probably thought
processes behind things uh that you
wouldn't not wouldn't normally see but
again they're completely partial of a
moment and that's why we need to wait
for the whole inquiry to report did you
uh do a little check to see what what's
UPS you've been exchanging with Matt
Hancock
um I will do now you've mentioned it
might be why
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh today Christine Harris
there my pleasure
my interview there with uh Chris Heaton
Harris I'm saying that he hopes to
cunningly persuade Boris Johnson to vote
for the uh brexit deal certainly a man
who is an optimist in that case given
Boris Johnson's public statement so far
plus of course uh confirming uh the uh
speculation that the government is going
to be bringing forward legislation to
ban people from claiming asylum in the
UK if they enter the UK illegally I will
hope more of that on the program
including Labor's reaction uh coming up
now we can speak to the shadow work and
pension secretary Jonathan Ashworth who
is talking to us from Central London and
good to have you on the program this
morning so do you back the government's
plan on small boats
well we've not seen the actual
legislation we'll study it carefully
we'll want to see whether there are
clear plans to tackle the The Gangs who
are smuggling people illegally across
the channel and put completely abusing
people we're told in the past that
they've got plans and legislation that
was going to deal with this problem and
their promises came to nothing and
actually we've seen more Boat Crossings
and the criminal gangs getting away with
more and more so we'll study it
carefully we'll also look to see whether
this will actually deal with the backlog
in a processing Asylum cases and it's of
course because of that huge backlog that
the criminal gangs are either are able
to exploit the situation now the
government have been in power now for 12
13 years they've allowed this backlog to
build up so we'll look at it carefully
we'll see if it actually practically
deals with the existing problems uh in
the system but I have to say we have
heard these promises before from
conservative politicians
you're absolutely right of course to
highlight the huge backlog in processing
Asylum claims which has a big knock-on
effect but just in principle Chris
Heaton Harris said that it's going to be
black and white very simple very clear
do you support the idea that it should
you should be banned from claiming
asylum in the UK if you enter here
illegally
well again we've not seen the actual
legislation we see conservative
ministers making big promises all the
time to get headlines but actually if I
may just to come in if I may because I
do understand that you haven't seen the
legislation you want to have a look at
the detail but I'm just asking you about
the broad principle
well the broad principle is that
refugees who arrive in this country we
have always welcomed them peoples whose
Asylum applications have been turned
down then of course they should be
returned that is a principle that we
have always accepted the problem is of
course the conservatives will come out
here and they will get headlines and
they will and they will say they're
going to do this that and the other but
they never deliver do they we were told
last year that their uh their borders
built was going to deal with this it
didn't so we will study it carefully but
we'll also want to see whether they're
going to crack down on those illegal uh
people smuggling gangs whether they're
going to deal with the Asylum backlog
because so far they have manifestly
failed on that front
position is that refugees should be
welcomed uh and of course many people
who come to the UK on small boats are
doing so because they're desperate right
they are fleeing persecution there may
not be any other way for them to get to
the UK and to put in an asylum claim
many of those claims are then granted so
if you do hold that position that
refugees are welcome surely you should
be opposing this plan
right
could reopen its doors up to people from
Ukraine from Afghanistan for example
but we're people traffickers are
exploiting this system and people's
Asylum case is uh turned down then these
people obviously have to be returned now
the government keep telling us they're
going to deal with this problem but they
never do so we'll study the details of
this bill when we actually see it and
we'll test it we'll hold it to hold the
government to account but I've got to
say hey they keep making these promises
they've been making these promises for
18 months two years or so and they never
deliver
what's Labor's plan
well vet Cooper has outlined a plan we
would invest in a proper crime agency to
really to really crack down on these
people smuggling gangs we will deal with
the backlog in Asylum claims because
that that clog where people can go for
months and months and months and months
and months uh sometimes Beyond 12 months
uh that is the the the gangs are
exploiting that aren't they so we've
outlined a plan to deal with the
problems in the system and we will test
this legislation on whether we believe
it will deal with the actual problems
that we've been highlighting
okay
to talk to you a little bit a little bit
and see gray and the Very heart of the
Civil Service is its reputation for
impartiality for serving and working for
the government of the day whoever it is
elected by the British people
how do you think it looks when a very
senior civil servant quits to become
chief of staff for the leader of the
labor party
Sue gray is a woman of exceptional
Talent abilities incredibly High Caliber
and in the same way in which senior
business people are now supporting the
labor party in the same way we have a
new crop of candidates of High Caliber I
think it shows how seriously people are
taking the prospect of kirst armor as
prime minister under labor government
and in turn in making this appointment I
think it reveals how seriously cursed
armor is taking our preparations for
government should the British people put
their trust in us at the next general
election she's a woman of immense
integrity and I'm I am delighted she's
uh hopefully coming to work for the
labor party
I guess my question is more about the
impression that it gives particularly
for those people who may believe rightly
or wrongly that the civil service is
effectively biased against the
conservative party in addition the
Privileges committee is looking into
Boris Johnson whether he misled
Parliament over partygate Sue gray of
course was the person who presided over
that inquiry has labor just handed Boris
Johnson and his allies the best ever get
out of jail free card they're already
saying that look you can't trust
anything that anyone says on partygate
because it was all a political smear
look so great she's now working for
labor
no not remotely remember Boris Johnson
said that Sue Gray's report validated
him and in fact the committee looking
into Boris Johnson's rule breaking at
the time when his conservative
government had put the country into
lockdown was a committee set up
unanimously by the whole of the House of
Commons has a majority of conservative
members of parliament on that committee
and has taken witness statements under
oath has relied on WhatsApp messages on
emails from Witnesses actually it's not
reliant on the Sue gray report because
she wasn't a witness to these parties it
was staff in number 10. many of whom
have I said given evidence to this
committee and this committee found out
on or reported on Friday that the
beliefs there is a case that Boris
Johnson May well have misled Parliament
so I know Boris Johnson's been on the TV
sort of trying to say that look this
brings the committee into question it
most certainly doesn't we've seen the
photo toes they're not photoshopped
Boris Johnson is there breaking the
rules when he put the country into
lockdown
okay well look we'll uh find out what
the Privileges committee has to say uh
later on uh of course I'm really
interested to get your view as well on
the other store that's been dominating
at the news for the last couple of weeks
Matt Hancock's WhatsApp messages while
he was Health sector of course during
the covid-19 pandemic you were shadowing
him at the time and I think in the
Sunday Telegraph today we can see that
he says he wanted to frighten the pants
or the public with the Kent they're in
to try and improve compliance with the
legislation rules
what's your reaction to seeing all of
this play out
I mean I think so many of these messages
are so troubling aren't they and I think
in the end it reinforces the case for a
proper full inquiry and we've got to get
it's got to get on we've got to get on
with this public inquiry I mean other
countries have completed their inquiry
we need at least some form of
preliminary report by the end of the
year all of this material has to be
handed over and I hope Rishi sunak is
insisting that all of this material from
any minister is handed over uh
in completely and I hope none of
ministers are deleting whatsapps are
anything of that nature I think it also
reveals that or confirms that many of
the concerns that we raise throughout
the pandemic the failure to put a
protective ring around Care Homes the
concerns that we had in Leicester where
we were in a longer lockdown that that
it turns out that Rishi sunat's policies
were actually helping spread the virus
which kept us in Leicester and people in
Berry and Bolton and Bradford in longer
lockdowns because of Rishi sunak it
confirms that there's a whole host of
mistakes were made that we were raising
at the time so we really do need a full
inquiry and the inquiry we need to get
on with it Rishi soon actually get a
grip of this and insist that we have
some form of report by the end of the
year you say that you're hoping
conservative ministers aren't deleting
their own whatsapps how about your
whatsapps if anything incriminating in
those would you be happy to hand them
over
uh there's nothing incriminating in my
whatsapps but obviously if anybody
wanted me to cooperate with an inquiry
of course of course I would but I wasn't
in the government I wasn't making
decisions
have you got any with Matt Hancock I
have uh Matt Hancock did WhatsApp me
from time to time but nothing as uh as
um interesting as what we've seen so far
I'm afraid anything you want to get out
before it appears in the telegraph
no no okay I don't think there's
anything interesting there
all right thank you uh very much indeed
Jonathan Ashworth uh speaking to us
there
you're watching at safer Ridge on Sunday
at lots already on the program whether
it's Matt Hancock's whatsapps uh or the
small boats policy plus still to come on
the program this morning we are going to
be talking to the vice president and
Stormont leader of chin Fane Michelle
O'Neill get her view on the brexit deal
and a little later we're going to be
hearing from the former Chief of the
general staff General Lord Dan had
always somebody who we're interested to
hear from on the program for his Frank
and honest Revelations about the state
of the army and also what is going on in
Ukraine too plus we'll get some reaction
from my Deputy prescriptions so Sam
capes who's watching all of our
interviews we'll speak to Sam a little
bit later on
[Music]
[Applause]
let's
oh right let's get uh the view now of
Michelle O'Neill because this time last
week all the talk was of the PM's deal
with the EU over Northern Ireland uh
protocol seemed to get a decent enough
reaction from most Parts but of course
the big question is what do the dep do
the largest unionist party in Northern
Ireland they say they won't rejoin power
sharing if they're not happy well the
largest party at stormland is sinfain
and its leader there would have been
first Minister that's Michelle O'Neill
she joins us live now uh thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning it has Rishi CNAC negotiated a
good deal for Northern Ireland
well I think we've all had the best part
of a week now to reflect on the deal and
I think it's fair to say that the
general assessment has been of course is
welcome I think in the first instance
people welcome the fact that a Dean has
actually been achieved that both sides
have signed up just something that this
is a departure from the previous
approach to the British government to
take unilateral action so I think it's
fair to say that in all of my
engagements throughout the course of the
last week particularly with the business
community that they feel this is a a
good deal and something in which they
can move forward on something that they
think that now leads to the restoration
of the executive which is where we all
should be in the aftermath of last
mayor's Assembly election and I think
that's where we need to be known to
maximize the huge economic potential
that we now have as a result of having
access to both the EU and the British
Market
the it's interesting that you say you
think that overall it's a deal that
should be welcomed particularly by those
in the business Community who feel
positive towards it the dep is still
considering it Chris Heaton Harris says
he's optimistic but of course they do
still have concerns about whether or not
Northern Ireland is being treated in
exactly the same way as the rest of the
United Kingdom particularly when it
comes to EU laws can you understand why
the unionists may still have concerns
okay I think at the end of the day we
all have concerns
um you know with an initially a way back
whenever brexit came about we voted to
reject brags that we wanted to stay
within the European Union we sought to
find protections and mitigations against
the hardest impact of it that came in
the form of the protocol and then we've
had this whole period of Uncertain day
instability unilateral action by the
British government and quite frankly
we've been treated as collateral damage
by success of British governments and
successive Tory leaders so I think the
fact that we now find ourselves in this
position today
where there's been a large body of texts
an agreement has been reached the
negotiation is complete it's now done so
I think where we all need to be focused
on is yes we have to work through the
detail and yes you know we do have some
concerns but we work our way through
that but we equally can do that on
tandem with having a restored executive
and I believe that's where we all should
be because right now we've had no
executive since last mayor's election
it's not good enough for people who are
dealing with across the living crisis or
people who are struggling to get seen in
the Health Service because our health
services in crisis so I think we can do
more than you know one thing at a time I
think that all parties should be back
around the executive table and actually
restore an executive immediately you
can't go on in an endless period of
scrutiny of the text
I want to talk to you about about the
restoring of the executive a bit later
but you know you'll stay there about
working through the details I guess what
the dup and some unionists would say is
look this isn't just details for them
this is you know the whole belief that
they have in being a unionist that
Northern Ireland should be treated by
exactly the same way as the rest of the
United Kingdom the same laws should
apply it should be exactly the same as
whether you're in Glasgow or Newcastle
or London so it's not just details for
them is it
unfortunately I mean I think there's no
consistency there because and many times
over the past particularly when it comes
to rates issues the dep have been happy
to be on a different side to what has
happened in Britain however I take on
board everybody's concerns I think
that's you know legitimate people are
entitled to express their concerns but
where we need to be right now and what
is needed from the dup right now is
leadership because they know that they
deliberately took a tactic
um they decided to walk away from the
executive in order to influence the
negotiation but the negotiation is now
complete so there's no reason for them
to stay outside of the executive they
should be back around that executive
table taking on the matters of the day
and then yes let us work through all of
the detail put this in the deal because
as I said I equally have some concerns
particularly around the statue of a
storm or break and what that might look
like and how it can be used because I
certainly don't want any game to create
you know replace a problem with the
problem but these are things we can do
waste also being in the executive so I
think that's where the wider public here
or the local community here uh the
people on the ground are saying well a
deal is now done so get back into the
executive and that's where I am ready to
be because Sophie we're about to embark
on a period where we will celebrate 25
years of the Good Friday agreement that
is something that's an enormous
achievement something that we should all
be very proud of and something that
again because we now have this deal
because we have access to both markets
because we have huge economic potential
we now need to be and bringing all that
International attention to our place
because of the celebration of the Good
Friday agreement we could have a
presidential visit from the United
States we could have this to become a
real economic Catalyst that will
actually grow our economy create jobs
better jobs this would be an opportunity
if this opportunity was missed that
would be so good just think so so
detrimental to what we could achieve in
this period by working together
are you talking about the anniversary of
the Good Friday agreements would you say
that the agreement and the peace in
Northern Ireland is in a strong place or
in a fragile place now
absolutely in a strong place I mean we
have come lips and bones in the last 25
years I am very proud of what our
society has achieved I am very proud but
collectively we all have achieved
because the when you think back to 1998
and where we are today in 2023 it's
completely transformed for the better
that's something that we should charge
and hold on to which is why whatever
brexit came about we said that the Good
Friday agreement and brags that weren't
compatible that you couldn't score that
Circle but we are where we are today and
and the one thing that the business
Community will be very strong on in
these common months when we have this
huge opportunity with the new US Envoy
being appointed to focus on the economy
with our Good Friday agreement
anniversary we need to be in that
executive because we need to be doing
delivering good public services for
people whilst also a villain of the huge
opportunity I found myself this week
actually strangely agreeing with the
British prime minister because whenever
Rishi Cena talked about the unique
position of the single Market
um the British Market having access to
both markets that is a huge opportunity
for us something that I'm quite sure is
an Envy of many people who live in
Britain you talked earlier to Chris
eaten Harris about Scotland and Wales
and potential that they would also want
to see that that same thing but the
British government gave that away but we
now have this unique selling point and I
want to maximize that and I want the
Good Friday agreement anniversary to
that on top of that um opportunity to be
a huge countless for investment here and
that should not be messed with the dup
can't go on in this being endlessly yes
everybody wants to do their due
diligence but then get around the table
and work and make politics work with the
rest of us do you think the dep are
serious about wanting to enter uh Power
sharing
well that's a question you're going to
have to put to them
um we obviously had a very historic
election last May of the very first time
a nationalist was returned as first
Minister and I am in the position of
first Minister designate did you be a
failed to honor that election at to this
point but I still um hope that they will
get to that point because the parish
earn is how politics works in the north
we have a special and unique
circumstance because of the Good Friday
agreement
um and there isn't any other alternative
in fact probably the alternative to
um part room would be some arrangement
between the British and Irish government
so I think where the public want us to
be is in the executive because otherwise
we're sitting on public services and our
public sector workers and our economy is
all being held around somebody and
policies that are taken in London by the
Tories who quite frankly have trained us
as collateral damage the whole way
through the past brexit a bit
um Cuisine Harris in the program earlier
said that look he hopes that what will
happen to the DP will back the deal and
they will go back into Power sharing but
he did say that if that doesn't happen
he is prepared to order another election
do you support him in that
but firstly I want to be an executive
that is my priority that's where I'm
going to continue to work
um to get to that point I think that's
what the public um want and expect of
their political leaders but you know the
Democratic rules are that if the
election isn't result isn't respected
then you do go to another election so I
mean I hope you don't get to that point
but if we do then we stand ready to
fight such an election
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh this morning really
interesting too thank you so much
well as usual the take is going to
follow this program that's just after 9
30 a chance to kind of Kick Back analyze
some of today's interviews talk through
any news lines uh we're always joined
with by our Deputy political editor Sam
Kate for that but again let's get a
quick take from Sam now uh shall we on
the interviews that we've heard uh so
far so it's been a lot of brexit a bit
on Boris Johnson uh we've had a little
bit on those Matt Hancock and messages
as well
um anything in particular catch your eye
well let's say fee good morning last
week was arguably Richie sunac's best
since becoming prime minister he landed
a more ambitious brexit deal that went
down better with a troubled conservative
party uh than many many accepted but I
think there are two things listening to
all the interviews this morning the
first is that you've got to remember
that deal hasn't passed yet and there's
a long journey uh before that happened
yet so much else it absolutely depends
on that being successful so this morning
of course the topic on the uh table uh
is migrants and the deal that uh
Richardson hopes to do with his own
party in the EU over that to stop the
small boats a lot of that depends on the
Northern Ireland stuff Landing properly
otherwise France won't engage as a
summit with macron on Friday but
domestically I think it's still not
quite clear that he's got the support
that he needs Everybody is watching the
dup Chris Heaton Harris the Northern
Ireland secretary said this morning he's
hopeful from what I can see actually the
dup sentiment is hardening against the
deal Chris Heaton Harris mentioned very
importantly in your interview there are
still talks going on he called them
technical talks I think the dep want to
upgrade that storm and break into
something a bit closer to a veto
something they're very unlikely to get
and could the Domino's start to fall
against Rishi sunat then if the dup
rejected it's a long and troubled route
before we get exactly what Richie's Cena
wants it was a great week last week but
there's hard yards to go on this
fundamental issue for his Premiership
yeah really hard job to go my is to
prick up actually when he said that look
the storm won't break is a veto we'll
have to I think see some of the details
on that to work out whether or not
that's just the spin that they're giving
to the dep or if it is a hard detail I
can see your face there that's a perhaps
as it all I will have more from Sam at 9
30.
now the small salt Mining City in
eastern Ukraine is the latest focus of
the war with Russian advances being held
back for the moment but the situation is
increasingly severe after months of
bombardment with reports of a possible
Ukrainian withdrawal as it could soon be
encircled
well we're joined now by the former
Chief of the general staff the former
head of the British army General Lord
Richard Danner always a pleasure to have
you on the program thank you for coming
on on a Sunday we're talking about back
moot what's your understanding about the
latest of that situation
well it would seem to me that the
ukrainians are going for very sensible
tactical decision that to withdraw
rather than run the risk of being
completely encircled um now makes sense
frankly black mood has been the focus of
first fighting since last Autumn it's
worth remembering that um it was the
wagon That Grew upon to brazosian that
um really wanted to try and show to the
Russian army that they could achieve a
victory whether which the Russian army
couldn't well this is dragged on now for
a better part of six months with huge
loss of life on the Russian side so from
the Ukrainian perspective you could say
that with buff mood pretty much smashed
the pieces now as a town as a city
there's nothing really worth defending
um strategically it's not very
significant but it's achieved its aim of
effectively being the Anvil on which so
many Russian lives have been broken and
therefore it makes complete sense for
the ukrainians now to withdraw to a more
defensible line uh and continue the
battle there because the really key
thing the overall thing is that
ukrainians need to hold the Russians
while the Russians amount their current
offensives and I don't think we've
really seen the real meat of that yet so
that at some point in the late spring
early summer the ukrainians can allow to
mount a really strong counter-offensive
utilizing the modern equipment that
we're now giving them
that's really interesting actually about
how you explain the kind of spread of
the war and the kind of strategy going
on I mean there's been a lot of talk
about a Russian spring offensive how
would you say that is going
well I don't think we've really seen it
start yet
um if they are serious about launching a
new offensive and I'm sure they are
because they've got to try and move the
war along in some positive direction
from the kremlin's point of view and
they've recruited and brought in maybe a
couple of hundred thousand maybe as many
three hundred thousand additional into
their army and of course but remember
these will be very poorly trained we
know they've been pretty poorly equipped
and they're very poorly LED it's going
to lead to significant loss of life on
the Russian side many Russian families
I've got to find that their husbands
Sons or other young people have been
taken away from them as the ukrainians
sit on the Strategic Defense for a while
and allow the Russians to throw
themselves into the teeth of of their
far apart it's when that has reached its
Climax and the as we would say the
Russians have culminated in their
offensive which I don't think will be
for a little while yet that's the moment
that the ukrainians must turn the table
on them and use the left with two tanks
the challenge of Tanks we've given them
the island infantry fighting vehicles
and self-propelled artillery and the
like to mount a really decisive
potentially decisive counter-offensive
and I think that I'm not alone in
believing that a few decisive blows
struck at certain points along that very
extended front on the Russian army could
well have the effect of breaking the
morale of the Russian soldier from
breaking the back of the Russian army
the thing is you don't have to defeat an
Army in detail everywhere on the
battlefield you've just got to convince
enough of its soldiers that they've lost
and when they think they've lost they
have lost
that's so interesting and it and for you
talking about you know the loss of life
on the Russian side as well and how
that's going to trickle back of course
because all of these men are going to
have families as well in Russia and
that's going to impact things as well
obviously
um you're talking about these decisive
moments coming up when Ukraine can use
the weapons and the Firepower that it's
been given do you think the West has
done enough in getting the equipment
that Ukraine needs to the front line
to be frank I don't think we've done
enough
um we need to do as much as we possibly
can to ensure that this war is concluded
this year and
well the debate is agonized for quite
some time when eventually the Germans I
think rather encouraged by us decided to
give leopard two tanks and a number of
other countries have followed that the
American Abrams Tanks won't be available
for quite some time and frankly fighter
jets won't be available for quite some
time so this counter-offensive by the
ukrainians is going to have to go with
what they've got bear in mind they've
got a lot of their own equipment still
they've got a lot of Russian equipment
that they've captured which clever
Ukrainian mechanics will have
refurbished and made available so that
showing their characteristic
determination their much better
operational planning they're much better
Battlefield leadership and discipline I
think there's every prospect that the
ukrainians can mount a successful
counter-offensive probably as I said
late spring early summer and um provided
that's planned properly and seen through
and we continue to give them as much
equipment and ammunition as they need
then there is a chance of having some
decisive outcome on the battlefield this
year none of us want to be here Sophie
this time next year discussing a war
that's in the Deep Freeze and dragging
on in our first world war traditional
type nature yeah absolutely right on
that um you're talking about the need or
the desire to try it and conclude the
ward this year but what does an end game
look like because you know frankly now I
can't imagine Putin just being like okay
right this is all a terrible mistake I'm
just going to get the guys out that's it
let's pretend it never happened
well I'd like to think that if the cams
are offensive by the ukrainians is
sufficiently well planned supported and
executed but Putin won't be in a
position to do too much decision making
himself that if his army crumbles and
runs then I think there's quite likely
that he'll be swept out of the Kremlin
as well and you'll also have to then ask
the question which everybody does is
well if it's not going to be a Putin in
the criminal who is it going to be well
to be honest I don't really know the
answer to that question but what I would
say is I think the group of people the
group of leaders who are most
disaffected in Russia at the present
moment are the senior generals they've
seen Putin totally interfere with a war
they probably don't largely agree with
they realize that their Weaponry is
distinctly inferior to that of the West
and that's largely through the
corruption in the Russian defense
procurement process so I could see
General grazimov the chief of the
general staff who's now been put in
charge in overall command uh in in
Ukraine itself to be the one if you make
sufficiently sensible plan and have the
moral courage to see it through it could
be the generals that topple the top of
the Putin and push him out of the
Kremlin
um there's going to be a lot of change
in Russia over the next 12 months I've
got no doubt that's fascinating and
actually one of the sort of a few times
that you can hear someone actually uh
arguing away forward
um that you can actually imagine
happening so well as you say there's
gonna be a lot of changes to come we're
gonna have to see how that unfolds I
just want to talk a little bit about the
UK defense if I may as well are you
concerned that sending so much
ammunition tanks obviously there's talk
about jets in the future as well whether
that could put the UK's defense
capability at risk
well I mean also by definition it does
but then you have to ask the next
question which does it matter
um who do we think we might have to be
fighting this year next year whatever
um the answer is difficult to tell
um it could well be Russia but the war
with Russia is currently going on and
Ukraine is fighting it so it makes
complete sense that we support Ukraine
to the maximum but the really important
thing or the additional important thing
is that we are firing up British
industry to make sure that we're placing
orders to replace our stock of in-law
anti-tank weapons all ranges of
ammunition and ask ourselves bigger
questions about our land Warfare
capability do we have plans for enough
main battle tanks in our Armory do we
have sensible plans for the next
generation of infantry fighting vehicles
and I think many of us would actually
think that our plans are not sufficient
and that the refresh of the integrated
review which is used to be published
this week and then the budget next week
frankly I and others hope that we will
see an increase in defense spending and
a significant proportion of that will go
on replenishing our land Warfare stocks
and improving our overall land Warfare
capability
yeah it's interesting there's lots of
talk isn't there about what will happen
with the defense budget the Sunday Times
reporting today which is soon I can set
to announce a multi-billion pound uplift
to the defense budget during potentially
a trip to the US
um Ben Wallace reportedly wants 11
billion pounds over two years I mean
that's not going to happen is that
I don't see why I shouldn't it's um it's
a lot of money but it's actually in the
totality of everything it's not a vast
and impossible amount of money yes of
course it's got to come from somewhere
and there are a lot of other demands on
the government's finances for money
elsewhere but at the end of the day are
the security of the Nations the safety
of our citizens is the number one
responsibility of government and defense
although some can argue it's fairly well
funded the balance within defense is not
right there is a deficiency in our land
Warfare fighting capability okay you can
say so if he he would say that wouldn't
he because he used to be in charge of
the army but it's a fact that most
independent observers would agree with
that the Army has been the poor cousin
in terms of investment over the last 10
15 years and frankly if we want to have
a credible Army that's got to change
okay thank you very much it's always
really interesting to get your
perspective thank you thanks Sophie
really interesting there to hear about
some of that analysis about the
importance of the spring and a potential
way out of the war as well but it
certainly feels like lots of twists and
turns to go in the absolutely
devastating war that we've seen we can
get the view live from Ukraine now where
we can speak to the Ukrainian MP and
chair of the Parliamentary committee on
EU integration Ivana climbush and sad to
see thank you so much for being uh with
us um there have been horrendous thank
you for having me thank you there have
been some horrendous reports of the
destruction in back moot what is the
latest you can tell us of what is going
on there
well unfortunately the Russian
Federation did not give up on the plans
that they had with regard to bahamuta
and they are still pushing on that
particular part of the Ukrainian
territory and I think the the approach
our military have been using their uh
withholding on to that particular city
is trying to uh deplete the Russian
federation's army
um as they are suffering their
incredible amount of incredible number
of human losses and I assume that
Ukrainian military management is also
looking into possibility to withdraw the
troops should the the losses of our
Armed Forces become unbearable
as this particular City or brother town
has a rather Tactical
significance in the in the whole battle
for our territory
we're just hearing from uh Lord dannett
before talking about the importance of
morale and the loss of life that you're
talking about as well with the Russian
forces how is morale within the
Ukrainian side
well obviously our forces of Defense are
you know significantly motivated uh to
protect the
um the motherland to protect our
civilians to protect their families
basically
um in in Ukraine so it's totally
different type of morale
um in comparison to what you have in the
Russian Armed Forces uh but definitely
it's also important to understand that
they are also tired and there is a um
uh so the significant amount of time
that a lot of our troops have spent in
the uh in the field specifically in the
front so I I'm seeing already some
attempts to uh to refresh the forces
also
um in the front line in order to to
ensure that everybody is having enough
uh strength to continue on uh with this
battle
as well about Western support
and the next few months could of course
be critical does Ukraine have the
weapons that it needs in order to beat
off any Russian offensive
you know with all
um really serious gratitude to what we
have been receiving from our partners in
the west we still have to ensure that
there is a clear uh sustainability of
all those weapons that are being
provided to Ukraine and the quality
quantity of weapons as well as the
urgency of their delivery uh to Ukraine
that's exactly what matters the most at
this particular moment as you said uh
and as we discussed the morale The
Bravery the the courage of Ukrainian
forces of Defense are still there very
much so but we are very much dependent
on the instruments and on the variety of
instruments that we can use in order to
both plan our counter-offensives and be
also
efficient in our defense of of the um
parts of our territory so therefore we
are not there yet when we can
um say for sure that the the
sustainability of that whole deliveries
are there to the extent that we need
them that's why we are focusing a lot of
our additional activities trying to
increase the number and the variety of
weapons that we have receiving different
from different capitals
there's a really disturbing story in the
Sunday Times today the British newspaper
you may not have seen it but it's
talking about children from Ukraine who
went to Russia perhaps they were said
that they were going on school trips and
never returned are there really these
cases of Ukrainian children disappearing
well I'm very very glad that finally
these stories are making it to the
international press we have been ringing
this alarm bells for quite some months
already but it did not gain that much of
attention
um in in the Free World so yes
unfortunately there are quite a few of
those stories we have about 13
um thousand cases that are confirmed
that uh Ukrainian children that we have
the confirmation that Ukrainian children
have been deported to different parts of
the Russian Federation however we also
have information about many more of that
those that are counted in tens of
thousands but we just do not have the
the official kind of recording of those
of those crimes and this is part of the
genocide that the Russian Federation is
conducting against Ukrainian Nation
because uh turning turning children
abducting them and and turning children
into different nationality by uh you
know spreading them around Russian
Federation and and actually giving them
to to Russian families that is just
another trace of genocide that is
ongoing right now in the center of
Europe
tens of thousands of Ukrainian children
disappearing do you have any sense of
what is happening to them
what we um there were a couple of cases
well basically uh that are counted in in
100 uh cases when we were successful
with the support of not unfortunately
governmental structures and uh but
rather non-governmental activities and
different uh human rights activists to
return some of those kids back so some
of them have been going through the
filtration camps with their parents
where they were separated from the
parents some of them have been taken to
so-called summer camps or like vacation
camps for a week from their parents and
then never never returned and they were
even some of them were even given on
already for adoption to Russian families
as if they didn't have their own
families back in Ukraine so um I think
the the scope of this of this absolutely
tragic activities that are uh being
carried out by the Russian authorities
we will learn only after we will be able
to liberate all the territories of
Ukraine and that is something that those
people who are suggesting peaceful
territories do not understand that the
SEC the the suffering
um the tragedies the tortures the
abductions deportations or um you know
on the territories that are right now
occupied by the Russian Federation are
absolutely tremendous and we have to
ensure that those people are liberated
by the Ukrainian
um Armed Forces
yourself in a teenage girls and I read
an interview that you did a little while
ago
um where you said my younger daughter
she was asking me mum could you promise
me that first and foremost you're not a
politician but first and foremost you
are my mum and if something is happening
your first and foremost take care of me
I just found that quote so
moving I guess
well I think that's every single
um you know Ukrainian
um
mature person that is serving the
country in this Advanced capacity has to
to ensure that we are doing all our best
for the for the country and those are
um different uh difficult
um and quite painful private choices
that that have to be made in order in
order to ensure that we have that uh
particular victory that we are so much
uh hoping for with the support of our
partners
well thank you so much for coming on the
program thank you I am doing a lot to
get the really important issues across
including those ones of those
disciplinary children so we appreciate
that
thank you
just before we go and a quick reminder
we do have a weekly um podcast so if you
scan the QR code on the screen right now
you can find the safer bridge on Sunday
podcast And subscribe so then it will be
in your feed each week we'll be joined
today by our political correspondent Liz
Bates and as usual by the show editor
it's called Beasley so you can find that
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts
just search for safety bridge on Sunday
always find those interviews from
Ukraine just completely mind-blowing um
and there's always new things to learn
no matter how many times we speak to
people from Kiev and elsewhere in the
country that is it for this week's
Sophia Ridge on Sunday in a moment after
the break we'll be running through
today's interviews and we'll be joined
by our Deputy particular editor Sam
capes thanks for joining us this Sunday
foreign
[Music]